COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some nursery experts with
their GCS upload performance.
Will we rock this
problem to sleep?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Bundle Cam is a company that
helps provide peace of mind
through durable,
high-performance nursery
cameras.
Their set up was pretty simple.
Every half second, the
camera would snap a photo
and store it locally.
Later, a batch of
those photos would
be uploaded to
Google Cloud Storage
for display and analysis.
The problem was that
they were seeing
that their upload times
for a batch of images
was painfully slow.
During the course of 20
minutes, this slow down
would result in
a serious backlog
of images that needed
uploading, eventually resulting
in the camera running out of
memory and stopping working.
At first glance, this could
be a cloud storage issue.
So let's run down the
list of things to test.
Firstly, we ran perf
diag on a sample bucket
that they created and verified
that it had a high throughput
from clients in the region.
This meant that the bucket
itself was performing properly,
in terms of connection and
upload speed from the client,
so that wasn't our problem.
Next, we checked that they
were using the fastest API.
As we we've shown,
the gsutil API
tends to be a tad slower than
the direct API counterpart,
but that wasn't
the problem either.
The cameras were on
embedded hardware,
so they were forced to
use the direct APIs,
rather than gsutil.
And they were using the
parallel upload API, so again,
no problem there.
At this point, I needed to
do some research myself.
So I turned to Michael
Yu's 2017 Next Talk
where he provided details on
how GCS works behind the scenes.
The important bit for us
goes something like this.
When uploading files to
GCS, the load balancer
will use file
names to decide how
to distribute connections
between shards
to handle upload.
As such, the more diverse
the file names, the better
the system can balance the load.
Likewise, the more
similar the file names,
the harder it is to
reach peak performance
when there's contention to GCS,
and that was exactly our issue.
The developer was using the
time stamp in the file path,
running right into this
performance problem.
The fix for Bundle
Cam was pretty simple,
prepending the hash of the
file name to the file name
itself, which allowed
GCS to better partition
the fixed range into shards
for better upload performance.
You can see the difference
between the linear file
names and the hashed
ones pretty easily.
To learn more about how Bundle
Cam improved their upload
performance, check out
the related article
linked in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]